>>I'm here on YouTube to talk about the economy
and the environment. Because clearly they
don't have enough people on the Internet talking
about this issue. How we're here in Davos
at the economic forum and here's what's going
on-where will the money go? Will it go to
energy? Will it go to the environment or will
it go to pump up this economy? Now there's
a lot of smart people that say they can do
both. So we'll see that in wind-energy. We'll
see that in a smart group that they talking
about now a stimulus package in Washington.
We'll see it all around the world, but the
question is can you save these industries,
can you save the car companies, can you save
consumers who are leaving their houses in
droves? Can you save all of it at the same
time? I wish I had the answer but I know it's
somewhere on YouTube.You guys go and look
for it. Thank you.